elbaradei road
escritos usados el año anterior para el
partido electoral y por sus matones que
estuvieron en todo el centro de
convenciones lo que estoy diciéndole a
ustedes es que ninguno de sus votos fue
inspeccionado como la ley requería no
incluso cuando una corte le ordenó a los
república y le ordenó y permitió el paso
a los republicanos de los opresores
republicanos
y así sacaron y movieron a la gente 60
pies más allá es realmente simple si no
hay nada que ocultar con estos votos por
correo
o no permite la infección es decir no es
sentido común prácticas comunes en el
examen el estudio de votos en ausencia y
esto pasa todo el voto
si nadie lo pone
hay una seguridad de tener firmas que
uno puede cotejar pero un método mucho
más inseguro de votos
la posibilidad de ver esos tarjetones
algunos de los actores que ustedes verán
se veían sospechosos desde muy lejos se
veían como él
es posiblemente la misma escritura no
puedo decir eso porque nunca pudimos
verlo
ahora ustedes también van a entender
encontrar que mucho más allá del otro
lado del estable
una situación similar
involucrando a tres tipos de tarjetones
que fueron que no fueron inspeccionados
no fueron revisados ni siquiera
observados por un republicano ni uno
solo tiene que haber un patrón
como bueno ya lo dicho no creo en
conspiraciones pero tampoco creo en
coincidencias es un poco exitoso que
todos los republicanos fueron rechazados
acá y todos republicanos fueron
rechazados en pittsburgh y esto suma una
cantidad de casi los 700 mil votos que
el presidente trump tenía como distancia
hace dos días que desaparecieron
y no teníamos forma de saberlo porque se
nos negó el derecho de inspeccionar
siquiera si uno de esos dos votos fuera
legítimo
eso no se había conocido antes es ilegal
y es inconstitucional y estaremos
llevando una acción desafío legal hago
énfasis aquí en con ustedes es que
solamente uno de los muchos otros
de las otras situaciones ilegales en
esta dirección
sé que hay ciudades que tienen historias
tristes de fraude electoral al final
joe frazier sigue votando acá es un poco
extraño ya que murió hace cinco años
pero joe sigue votando si yo recuerdo
correctamente yo era un republicano
entonces de pronto el niño debería
quejarme pero deberíamos ver si yo voto
de por un republicano por demócrata
desde la tumba también el padre de will
smith ha votado aquí dos veces desde que
murió no sé cómo votar porque su voto en
secreto pero en filadelfia mantiene los
votos de la gente huelga secretamente al
menos eso es algo que uno puede bueno
que no los puede felicitar cierto yo no
estoy atacando el pueblo de filadelfia
estoy atacando a su maquinaria decrépita
demócrata
y hay otras regiones para atacar han
pasado 65 años siguen eligiendo los
mismos la gente no mejora la ciudad no
mejora el crimen llega al hecho los
motines la policía se queda a ver uno
por ser policía sea porque hay un
alcalde que les permite quedarse parados
y observar hay un fiscal general que
deja ir a la gente
no les sirven bien señoras diseños de
filadelfia y de enfrente de pronto tiene
una maquinaria política y los alcaldes
los alcaldes que dejan que ocurran los
bueno los fiscales que dejan ir a los
criminales yo no creo que se preocupen
mucho por el fraude electoral
esto es increíble es una disputa
importantísima con un método muy
sospechoso de votación no había
seguridad pero pipo la gente de esta
ciudad de la gente de este país no tiene
ningún tipo de certeza de que esos
tarjetones fueron depositados
unánimemente pero joe biden para que
alcanzara la diferencia y déjenme hacer
que aquí pasen un par de personas hoy
quiero hacer énfasis 2 o 3 de 50
personas hasta ahora que nos han dado
declaraciones affidavits grabaciones
vamos a tener muchos testigos pero no va
a ser un caso pequeño va a ser un caso
grande pero quiero que tengan una idea
de la situación en filadelfia porque
también hay que alertar a la gente de
pittsburgh de que el mismo fraude les
ocurrió a ellos así como aquí y también
quiero agregar que lo mismo fue hecho en
georgia
lo mismo fue hecho en michigan lo mismo
fue hecho en carolina del norte me
parece que alguien del comité nacional
demócrata enfría una pequeña nota que
decía no permitan que los republicanos
observen esos votos llegados por correo
al menos no en estas ciudades demócratas
increíblemente grandes que controlamos
hemos hecho mucho por contra la sociedad
y ahora vamos a destruir su derecho a
votar